[موسيقى]
ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد خبرنا على مين
صار لاكثر من 40 مليون شخص في جميع انحاء
العالم يصابون بالمرض فاقد اكد تجربه لكيه
جديده فاعليه دوائر جديد للزهايمر من شانه
تدمير المرض للدماغ ويخفض التدهور المعرفي
لدى المرضى في المراحل المبكره من المرضى
واكدت نتائج الكامله لهذه الدراسات هذه
النتائج التي اجريت على نحو 1800 شخص تمت
متابعتهم على مدارس 18 شهرا انخفاظا بنسبه
27% من التدهور المعرفي لدى المرضى الذين
توصلت اليه مجموعه الادويه اليابانيه
ايسائي والاماراتيه بيوجين من جانبه قلم
مدير ومعهد الابحاث المتعلقه بالخراف في
معهد بريطانيا ان هذا هو دواء الاول الذي
يقدم خيارا علاجيا حقيقيه للاشخاص
المصابين بمرض الزهايمر واضاف انه على
الرغم من ان الفوائد السريريه تبدو محدوده
نوعا ما الا انه من المتوقع ان تصبح اكثر
وضوحا اذا تم تناول الدواء لفتره اطول
[موسيقى]
نفهم اكثر هذا الموضوع مع ضيفنا من باريس
الدكتور الفيرم خبر دكتور علوم الاعصاب و
اخصائي العظم النفسيه اهلا بك معنا دكتور
دكتور البير في الواقع كانت هناك تجارب
عديده
وكثيره كذلك بخصوص امكانيه ايجاد حلول
الزهايمر من خلال بعض الادويه ولكن هذا
الدواء فيما يختلف حتى يقول عنه
الاخصائيون بانه قد يمثل بارقه امل حقيقي
مرحبا
انا بصراحه بعرف انه في حماس كثير صعبه
يمكن شويه لازم لازم
نحد منه لانه مثل حضرتك عم تقولي في كثير
ادويه بيطلعوا عن الامراض
اللي كثير صعبه للمرضى وللعائلات تبعهم بس
وقت نطلع بطريقه شويه اكثر دقيقه عن
الدراسه اللي طلعت عن الدراسه
[موسيقى]
همم شويه ساره بالوضع يعني منهم
ممم
واو قد ما ادمع بنتخيلوا مثلا كثير عم
بينعاد
بالاعلام اللي هو شيء طبيعي لانه مش
اخصائيين انه صار في 27% تحسن بس هذه قيمه
مطلقه مطلقه واحنا يلي بهمنا هي القيمه
النسبيه همم بين الاشخاص وتطلع القيمه
النسبيه بالدراسه
ان هو فقط
شويه بال- بالتفاصيل اذا في بعض المشاهدين
همم
بفرشيه هو انه همم البنت عامله لايت كده
مفكرينه جزء همم اساس من من مرض الزهايمر
ولحد نلاحظ هلا انه هي شقفه صغيره من من
مره شكله كثير اكثر معقد
[موسيقى]
شيئا اكبر همم ما التفاصيل اخرى ولكن عن
هذا الدواء يعني هناك تجارب كلينيكيه تقول
بان هذا الدواء من شانه ابطاء تدمير المرض
همم للدماغ ويخفف التدهور المعرفي لدى
المرضى في المراحل المبكره تقول دكتور
بانه لا يجب ان همم مصارع بالفرح او
باعلان همم النجاح همم لماذا اليست بدايه
همم يمكن بناء عليها او هناك نقاط استفهام
تعتقد بانه يجب ان تطرح ويعمل عليها في
المستقبل
100% في كثير نقاط استفهام اول شيء هو انه
اللي كان معه بالمرضيه اللي راح اقول لك
تحسنوا نصف نقطه
بالادرات الفكريه مثل مثلا الذاكره اما حل
المشاكل يعني هو شيء كثير صغير همم على
همم يعني ما بدك تفوت كثير بالتفاصيل بس
هو شيء كثير كثير صغير ثاني
في كثير عوامل همم جانبيه لها المرض
تقريبا 44% من المرضى همم كان عندهم عوامل
جانبيه 22 21 منهن صار عندهم تضخم بالدماء
همم وبعض العمر همم نزيف همم همم
والشخصين كان عندهم حتى عوامل وادي للموت
تبعهن ولكن عم ياخذوا كمان مسيل للدم اذا
مثلا كان احد عنده امراض بان هذا المرض
فيه التقاء لعوامل عضويه وعوامل نفسيه
وبالتالي يصعب تحليله كشفه همم ليس كشفه
ولكن كشف دواء ناجع همم درجه مئه بالمئه
خاص به
لهلا بعدنا بمراحل نفهم همم هالمره كيف
بيمشي كيف بحط حاله للاسف بعرف انه في طلب
وكلنا عنا عيالنا اشخاص مصابين من المرض
بس العالم العالم شيء بطيء للمواضيع
الصعبه
ولازم نتبع ونتريه وتكون عام نوع عود
بعود كبيره لمرض مثل هايبر امراض مثل
السرطان امراض الامراض
بس ال- ال-
هل هناك
النصائح يمكن تقديمها للناس هل هناك بعض
النصائح تقي من هذا المرض نعم اول شيء
بنعرف انه
الحياه همم
اكتف بتساعد
نشيطه نعمل همم
تشيكوبس نروح نشوف الحكيم على اول الشكوك
حسب العمر تبعنا لانه بنعرف نعمل تشخيص
بقى مبكر عنا احسن ان ادوات احسن لن اخر
مره
خيبر دكتور علوم
النفسيه شكرا لك لن نقاش دائما باقيه
السلام عليكم